foreign
I hope you're still staying active on a
daily basis with our workouts today's
workout is a total body strength and
conditioning workout what you'll need is
a pair of medium weight dumbbells
between three to five kilos each so
there will be a total of eight exercises
each workout will last for 45 seconds
with 15 seconds rest in between are you
ready it's going to work on your entire
body we want to focus on a lot of
compound movements and you will get your
heart rate pumping so grab your
dumbbells
I'm going to go for four kilos each now
before we start our workout let's do a
three minute warm-up all right so stand
shoulder width apart with your toes
pointed forward and let's start with
some nice and easy Dead Leaves keep the
dumbbells close to your thighs
and up and squeeze your glutes back down
up and squeeze your glutes so you should
feel the stretch along your hamstrings
and as you come up you should feel your
core working as well as your thighs and
your glutes nice down and up very good
let's just wake the muscles up get your
blood flowing up and squeeze give me a
couple more
up
down look down and squeeze up now drop
one dumbbell let's do squat with
shoulder presser case so I want you to
grab one dumbbell with both hands drop
into a squat as you come up push up into
a shoulder press so back down up push up
into a shoulder press again with squats
push your butt back
and draw the dumbbells up nice down go
as low as you can and if you can tap
your elbow onto your knees down
bring it back down and up do not hunch
forward or do not tiptoe okay so back
down push up with your heels and draw
the dumbbell straight up and work on
your shoulders done again and up give me
a couple more down and up very good now
grab both dumbbells let's do some bends
over row to warm up on your back so bend
from your waist bring the dumbbells
close to your waist and just squeeze
your back
up and down nice and easy up and down
very good
so you should feel your meat back and
your lats working
now a few more squeeze up and down
and just nice and easy breathing
one more up and down drop the dumbbells
down
let's work on some dynamic stretches
okay so I'm going to step forward reach
up lunge forward and bring your legs
back up
and back stretch up for your core
stretching and reach up good
few more stretch up back
up and back
last one
and good now just shake it out first
workout will be squat with single arm
shoulder press so only using one
dumbbell what I want you to do is Step
slightly wider the shoulder width apart
with the toes pointed forward okay bring
the dumbbell right in the center as you
squat down lift the dumbbell off the
floor and flip it up into a nice
shoulder press again bring it back down
up into a nice shoulder press good let's
go down
and up remember you're squatting down
okay you're not just bending from your
waist so bend your knees bring it down
drive it up and squeeze good
down up and squeeze give me a couple
more and we want to switch sides
last one
and now bring it back down left arm up
into a shoulder press
remember you're squatting down so draw
your bum down towards the floor
if you're doing this this is wrong okay
squat down drive it down and press it
back up good next workout bend over roll
with a dead lift so grab both dumbbells
I want you to start with a dead lift
down and up and as you come down give me
three
bent over row squeeze okay ready let's
go down up down home one two three
squeeze and up again up
Arch squeeze your glutes and now let's
work on your back
and up good bend over row
squeeze and
roll it close your waist draw it towards
your abs and up
remember to breathe in
and breathe out
two three and back up
last one more up squeeze and one two
three and up good
right this next workout is going to work
on your upper body push-ups your core as
well as your shoulders so start in a
push-up position both dumbbells on the
floor okay give me a nice push-up I'm
going to hop both legs in and bring this
up okay that's it so this is going to
work on your cardio as well down up
bring it up and press it up that's it
again down push it back into a nice
push-up
in and bring it up if this is too
challenging what you can do is take a
step back into a push-up take a step in
into a shoulder press that's it so
choose the option step out
push up step in
show The Press so bring both legs close
together okay hop out
and hop in
that's it a few more keep going five
seconds last one out
in
and up good right side to front raise
still working on your shoulders your
upper body your triceps okay grab both
dumbbells raise them to your side and
immediately draw them to the front out
to the side and bring it back down okay
nice and controlled side Bring It
Forward out and side good to the side
forward
this is not easy if this weight is too
heavy for you you can always choose a
lighter option nice so suck your belly
in control and get your core and really
use your shoulders
as well as your chest muscles and also
your upper back good spread it out bring
it back down a few more 10 seconds
bring it back down up
forward out and side last one up forward
out and side now let's get back to work
on your lower body as well as your
obliques lunge and twist okay so bring
both dumbbells together okay bring them
close to your chest step right at the
edge of your mat step forward and twist
on the opposite side step back
forward on the opposite leg and twist
that's it so you're working on your legs
as well as your oblique with that slight
twist forward and twist very good
remember again you're pushing up with
your heels and you're engaging your core
to find that balance push up
and forward
and up good
keep going now
up
and breathe out
so breathe in
and breathe out good
a few more twists
and up last one more twist and up get
down onto the floor we're going to work
on chest press chest press with the
bridge okay so draw your bum up imagine
there's a line pulling your hips towards
the ceiling bring both dumbbells up
spread it white into a chest press and
squeeze it good so your toes should be
pointed forward and your glutes should
be you should be squeezing your glutes
okay up and squeeze
nice lift the high up Do not drop lift
it high up
and nice and controlled
draw your elbows down tap gently
just tap do not rest them and push them
back up
good bring them down
up
down and up
nice keep going
give me one more squeeze squeeze squeeze
High
and down drop one dumbbell onto the
floor okay we want to work on full
extension so grab one dumbbell with both
hands
straighten your legs extend as you
crunch up squeeze
and extend that's it so draw your knees
towards your chest
and squeeze good extend fully
up and squeeze nice
remember to always keep your lower back
on the floor do not Arch your lower back
extend
and knees to chest
squeeze lift your shoulders off the
floor
keep going
feel your upper as well as your lower
abs working
squeeze
breathe in breathe out last one more
breathe in breathe out good job last
Core workout drop both dumbbells okay we
don't need any dumbbells for this
Spiderman so get into a high plank
position for this workout and I want you
to bring your knee to meet your elbow
ready let's go knee meeting your elbow
and the opposite side good
so again this workout
targets your core as well as your
obliques okay remember to keep your back
flat do not Arch up or drop your hips
okay keep them straight and bring your
elbow to your knee
good
keep going last workout and you will get
a solid one minute break
breathe in control your breathing and
breathe out
all right
I can see my sweat dripping that's one
more
and press it on that was your first set
done I'm sweaty I'm feeling really good
you have two more sets to go okay so
grab some water wipe your sweat take
this time to really breathe and just
relax we're not rushing
we're completing two more sets
keep yourself hydrated okay
oh
right you have about
20 30 seconds of rest so for the second
set I want you to really give your best
effort to focus on proper form make sure
that you're not just rushing through the
workout but you're feeling every muscle
being worked okay so this is also the
time for you to adjust your weights if
you want to grab heavy dumbbells go
ahead if you feel that it is too heavy
and you want to go for lighter dumbbells
you can do that as well so let's start
with the first workout grab one dumbbell
and it's going to be a squat with single
arm shoulder press okay so stand
shoulder width apart just slightly wider
than shoulder width apart then squat
down and up with your shoulder press
nice so down and up
good squad back down look forward and
press it up
and remember to breathe okay so breathe
in and breathe out as you press up give
me one more on this side
and now let's switch side good up and
press
back down
and press
good
squat down and press it up through your
shoulders
down and up it's just a gentle tap on
the floor and press it up one more down
and press it up good second workout
working on your back grab both dumbbells
deadlift to bend over row okay so
shoulder with a pad
relax your knees keep them soft and now
let's start with a dead lift down
squeeze your glutes go back down and
three bend over rows
up
and squeeze back down
squeeze down hold it there and three
good up again down
up down and hold it
squeeze your mid back and back up
nice keep going
look straight down and hold it one two
and three all the way up now let's get
into one deadlift up
hold it
and squeeze good
last few more and done now push up two
shoulder press okay choose your option
you can either hop into the workout or
you can step in okay so let's start on a
high Plank and let's start with push up
all right ready let's go push up hop in
narrow and shoulder press nice
kick it back down up hop in
and push it up again if this is too
challenging you can take a step back or
you can do the push-up on your knees
okay down back
and a nice deep push-up bring the chest
close to the floor chest close to the
floor up hop in
and push up
good
keep going guys it's only 45 seconds of
work push up
and back down give me one more push up
in and draw it up all right good still
working on your shoulders side to front
raise okay so grab both dumbbells if
this is too heavy you can always go for
the lighter weight dumbbells okay so I'm
going for three kilos each up to your
side
and bring it forward
yes you should feel your muscles working
you should struggle but you shouldn't be
struggling too much that you can't get
your form right so bring it side and
drop it good hold it hover it bring it
to the forward and drop nice up Bring It
Forward
open it up and drop and get your core
keep your body upright do not arch your
back okay this is wrong so engage
and bend your knees slightly drop it
back down
up
I can really feel my shoulders shaking
and the muscles are screaming
and down nice
lunge and twist so just drop the weights
let's hold both dumbbells let's step
back start right at the edge of your mat
bring both dumbbells close together
right in the center lunge forward and
twist good step back
forward and twist
keep going down and twist
down
twist
so look straight ahead to find your
balance push with your heels and step
forward take a wide step
and twist good
wide step both legs should be in a 90
degree position
lunge down
and step back
alternate legs okay and step back
all right go down
draw your knee
as low as you can towards the floor
bring it back
down and back nice let's get down onto
the floor
hip bridge and also chest press so let's
start high up okay both dumbbells up
lift your hip off the floor toes points
are forward and now let's go
into a chest press
I want you to really be conscious and
just squeeze your glutes okay squeeze
your glutes throughout the entire 45
seconds as well as
controlling the dumbbells and drawing
them close to the floor and pressing
them up if you find yourself wobbly that
is absolutely fine this workout will not
only strengthen your muscles it will
also strengthen your joints and your
bones okay so slowly control nice and
control and press
draw your hips High
squeezer glutes Do not drop them up up
squeeze
and control and press
good job now let's just drop one
dumbbell down let's get into full
extension okay so one dumbbell with both
hands
exhale leg straight draw it back
crunch
extend all the way back crunch up
extend
crunch up and extend good there you go
lift your shoulders off the floor okay
lift your shoulders it's not about
bringing your neck off the floor relax
your neck look straight ahead as you
crunch up and draw your shoulders off
good
crunch in try to reach the dumbbell
to your ankles nice straight legs crunch
keep going
up and down
feel
your abs burning and good drop both
dumbbells down
find a co-workout Spider-Man
it is a love-hate relationship it is not
an easy workout but it is an extremely
effective workout so get into a high
plank let's go
knee to Elbow
and knee to Elbow a gentle tap and tap
if you can't reach that's okay just go
as far as you can if this is too
challenging drop onto your knee and just
reach onto your knee and just reach okay
I believe that everybody needs a
starting point so choose your starting
point and slowly progress as you
progress up to your toes and reach nice
keep going
knee to elbow knee to Elbow okay
you're doing so well and you're getting
another solid one minute break right
after this workout
ah oh my God
right that was round two done one more
set to go you wanted a full length
workout so I'm giving you a full length
workout okay we are not stopping right
now drink some water wipe your sweat I'm
sweating you should be sweating just
bring your heart rate back down slightly
breathe and I want you to end the final
step strong only eight minutes of
workout only eight minutes
right guys how you feeling
feeling good I know I am
this workout is so I love this kind of
circuit training because it doesn't only
work on my strength but it's also
getting my cardio up there and I love
the feeling of just feeling my muscles
burning and working right grab one
dumbbell okay squat with a single arm
shoulder press let's go down and push up
as many repetitions as you can keep
going
final sad
fire on push through let your muscles
burn okay for your size for your glutes
for your shoulders Let Them Burn because
your sweat is your fat crying now switch
side okay good keep going
press it up
down and up
nice deep squat okay draw your bum down
nice deep
squat look straight ahead open up your
chest this is the new year the new month
for you
to be amazing right both dumbbells
bent over row and also deadlift so let's
start with deadlift toes pointed forward
relax your knees and let's go down
controlled up squeeze the glutes down
and three rows
back up again squeeze engage down up
squeeze down and three rows very good
and now release
you should also feel your hamstrings
working okay if you have tight
hamstrings you will really feel it
down and up
and one two three nice
few more keep going we don't stop when
we're tired remember that we stop when
you're done okay and you're not done
just yet so stay with me stick with me
very good my favorite workout I know
it's your favorite as well push up to
show the Press I mean who doesn't love
this workout come on
so then again let's go ready let's go
push up hop in choose your option up
into a nice shoulder press so push both
legs back
push up oh
draw your butt down as you hop in and
bring your butt back okay so draw your
butt down
and push up so it should be jumping into
a narrow squat and up
nice keep going guys
down
and up feel your heart rate feel that
burn
that's a good burn okay whenever you
push yourself when you work out the
afterburn is even more amazing your body
continues to burn calories even after
you work out so take this time and
really push yourself good now drop both
weights I'm going to go for slightly
lighter okay so three kilos
for my side to front raise
oh
breathe
no time to breathe let's go side to
front
side to front
and go hover draw it to the front Do not
drop keep it at your eye level at your
shoulder levels
and bring it to the side good keep your
back flat
knees soft and to the side very good
halfway there guys halfway there I know
this is burning I know your shoulders
are on fire because my shoulders are on
fire
all right but you will get sexy arms up
forward and down good
give me two more okay and down give me
one more
let's go up forward side and done well
done
right
back to your legs back to your core
lunge and twist
so choose your weights okay step right
at the edge of the mat my hair is messy
I'm sweaty but who cares let's go you
should be sweaty and your hair should be
messy twist and go back nice lunge
forward look straight ahead and twist
foreign
you are almost there okay you have only
three more workouts to go and that's
only three minutes left
let's keep going squeeze down twist as
far as you can and look the opposite
side twist and look at the opposite side
good down twist ten more seconds down
and twist
push back with the heels
and twist
last one down and twist now let's get
down onto the floor okay
chest press with hip bridge so lift your
hips off
shoulders up dumbbells up open it up
squeeze your glutes ready and down and
squeeze okay when you're right at the
top I'm going to squeeze both chest and
draw them together squeeze good
squeeze and hold everything for one
count bring it back down and up nice
done it up down and up good control tap
and squeeze remember to keep your wrist
straight okay do not over arch your
wrist all right and the dumbbells should
always be in line with your chest
not too high or not too low
nice and controlled
going
I can feel my glutes
and just drop one weight down
let's get into full extension
both hands holding one dumbbell extend
over your head legs straight out and
ready
let's get into a full crunch
and extend out good crunch in bring the
dumbbell to your ankles crunch in extend
it out
crunch in and extend
very nice keep going
breathe out breathe in
breathe out there you go in and out
so the more you're able to learn and pay
your breathing the longer you will be
able to push yourself in your workout
okay it's not just about your strength
but it is also about your breathing so
extend it out and crunch in guys come on
keep going you have only one more minute
left right after this just one more
workout okay drop both dumbbells down
let's get into your final workout
Spider-Man
to it whoa 45 seconds left all right
let's go
crunching
bring it in very good
I can see my sweat dripping
every sweat is basically my effort of
pushing myself through the workout and
giving my body only the very best
because I know that I want to start this
year Strong full of energy and not only
will I look good I will feel good and
you will give me better focus keep going
guys you only have 10 seconds left what
is 10 seconds all right keep driving
your knee to your elbow and right after
this you will get a nice and easy
cooldown ah well done right now let's
just get into a child's pose okay to
stretch it out just relax
take this movement to Just Breathe
bring your hobby back down
and just connect with your mind and your
body okay
just relax and breathe
and now
I just want you to oh it won't stop I
just want you to bring
fly forward
and slowly
push up into a cobra
draw your shoulders down and just look
up feel your lower back being stretched
out
and just breathe
okay do not Punch or Draw your shoulders
up push it down
and just look up and from this position
let's get into downward dogs so push
your butt up
and just draw
your heels to the floor
into a high mountain pose okay
and just look between your legs
flatten your back
push your palms push your legs push your
feet into the floor
if you want to
just
go into
walking dog okay so alternate one leg at
a time and just feel the stretch on your
calves
[Music]
foreign
now draw your right leg forward step
forward
drop your left knee down and I just want
you to stretch
drop your weight forward feel your hip
flexor being stretched out and just
twist on the opposite side okay just
twist and look as far back as you can
good just keep breathing
and now straighten your leg
stretch your hamstrings
keep breathing
see even when I'm just warming down my
sweat is just constantly dripping
because my body does not just stop
burning right after my workout it will
continue to burn for the next 24 hours
and that's why this kind of workout is
so effective short but you will see the
long-term results
and just Bend forward
and this stretch will work on your
glutes okay
and now draw your leg back
let's switch on the other side okay so
left leg or whichever leg forward
and I'm going to twist and look
as far back as you can
straighten your back okay do not hunch
open your chest straighten your back
good and now straighten the leg the
front leg and draw your upper body down
and feel the stretch on your hamstrings
and now Bend
and just drop your upper body forward
and stretch out on your hip flexor as
well as your glutes if this is too
difficult you can always start on your
palms okay start high up and as you
progress as you get more flexible drop
onto your elbows
and the further you inch forward the
more you will feel the stretch
good and now just slowly push yourself
up
okay
and I'm going to just sit up sit tall
and just open your chest so stretch your
chest out from all the chest workout
Point both thumbs down
and stretch your biceps out
and just shake it side to side
and
that was a solid 30 minute total body
strength and conditioning workout I'm
sweating like crazy my heart rate is too
high up there and I'm feeling so amazing
I challenge you to complete this workout
and complete every single daily workout
on the field app okay don't forget to
share this workout on with your friends
get them to join you and get them to
join the daily challenges as well
because you guys will stand a chance to
win amazing prizes
all the best